les bars les restos des terrasses rempli
de clients
pas de distance pas de masque une image
qui paraît sorti des archives de l'ère
pré covin mais en israël
c'est la nouvelle réalité un avant goût
pour le reste du monde de ce à quoi peut
ressembler la vie après le coronavirus
l'étudiant inscire moche et possède
plusieurs bars et restaurants dans cette
rue piétonne de jérusalem il se sent
revivre l aco vide
c'est comme une bouteille de champagne
que l'on n'ouvre dit il tout le monde
veut sortir parce qu'on a été enfermé à
la maison si longtemps c'est un axe fort
longtemps
c'est le cas tu as dame alia et de sa
femme morts on se sent bien
c'est le retour à la normal dit il et ça
fait longtemps qu'on ne s'est pas senti
comme ça
israël a été l'un des premiers pays à
vacciner massivement sa population grâce
à une entente spéciale avec la compagnie
pfizer
aujourd'hui près de 60 % des israéliens
ont reçu leurs deux doses de vaccin
contre à peine plus de 5 % au canada
un chiffre qui s'ajoute à tous ceux qui
ont développé des défenses naturelles
après avoir été exposés au virus
résultat il n'ya presque plus de
contagion selon cet épidémiologiste
l'objectif de l'immunité collective est
atteint santini ont été d'après lui le
succès israélien s'explique en grande
partie de l'addition des populations par
la mise en place de laisser passer vers
a été un facteur important dit il c'est
à motiver les gens à accepter le vaccin
laissez-passer vert est un certificat
numérique remis à ceux qui comme moi se
sont fait vacciner ou à ceux qui ont
récupéré la coved
c'est surtout un sésame exigé à l'entrée
des lieux publics mais fermé comme ici
les restaurants les hôtels les jim ou
les salles de spectacle c'est surtout un
formidable incitatif pour se faire
vacciner
c'est d'ailleurs cette promesse de
retrouver sa liberté qui a convaincu des
veines clique de surmonter sa peur des
vaccins et vaccination générale me rend
nerveux tél mais je crois que cela
valait vraiment la peine
depuis minuit heure locale de laisser
passer vers n'est plus nécessaire le
couvre visage non plus c'est donc une
énorme chape de plomb qui est levée
l'occasion de chanter danser de célébrer
la vie et l'insouciance
retrouvez ici jean françois bélanger
radio canada que vous allez m